okay everybody's sorry we're starting
this a little later than expected um and
we are talking about incremental
language development oh look at that
number point two automatic merge to
twelve points
Oh top why - well well that's that's the
question do we want it in four point one
I think it'd be wonderful to have it in
twelve point one let me look at what it
does and have we talked to Brad about
this is Brett here by any chance he's
not we see if we can get him yeah so it
effectively removes the point in there's
no after it because it's go very good
and the defaults thinking for sure
percent form to automatic yes it was
already doing this
I think scientific form it should be
automatic as well wait what do you mean
I was already doing it it was doing it
in a hacky way by actually explicitly
setting the number point to null string
or something in percent form what you
requested it passed these so it was
doing it always it wasn't possible to
undo it I see I see I see
um is that correct
Danny
sorry my screen froze on me and I had to
get off for a moment what what was the
question
what discussing yeah yeah automatic
intercept form is what you're always
doing this right yes okay even that was
something you explicitly no no it was
very good it's very very good okay look
here's a case that okay I believe three
point times ten to the seven is never
desirable but I'm thinking of some
scientific situation in which you want
to stress that that's all the
information you have but is still not
accessible but but the fact is you never
we don't do three times ten to the seven
for exact numbers ever you can't ever
get that if you have an exact number
there's no way to turn it into
scientific notation
what will scientific form do with an
exact number if you want to just test it
real fast
Splatt nothing which is probably wrong I
mean that probably should come back as
three times 10 to the 11 I don't see why
it wouldn't well expect numbers like
integers and fractions and rationals do
not do anything
under any of their yeah I don't think we
want to be changing there
fine fine fine fine okay but then I'm
making the claim that 3 times 10 to the
11 never wants to be 3-point times 10 to
the 11 so you want all of these to
default to automatic no no no scientific
notation I think that's ugly
I just don't think anybody would ever
write that and I don't think it's
necessary because by the time you're
saying 3 times 10 to the 11 you know
it's an exact thing what do other people
think I mean this feels to me like a lot
of the around ISM that you did I think
is work beautifully of um so you know
let's use around like thinking so to
speak on on the case of number points
well that's my suggestion is that we
removed the number point in in that in
in that case by default so I mean in a
sense that's a number point arrows
something even more than automatic right
because that's a number point that's
there's different specifications then
for the scientific notation version
versus the what does an ordinary number
form do what is the ordinary number form
do if I say five digits does it go to
scientific notation or what yes that's
our boy we had an option to control
their deaths results
I see so we've got that well that
default doesn't horrify me that much
actually three point so I don't see any
reason why we were drawn to change what
n does in terms of formatting well it's
not ends both I mean it's just okay I
think this is a higher-order issue but I
think right now if I do this well it's
it I can't do it here but if I do this
with with version 12 and I say number
point are automatic then I will just get
3 times 10 to the 11 man correct yeah
you should I'm sorry with with number
form yes yes yeah yeah so as we keep it
as it is and then we start seeing if
users use number point automatic
incentive for fine
Brian I livestream is saying doesn't
leave in decimal point indicate number
of significant digits not really
unfortunately three point doesn't really
tell you very much other than that it's
an exact number and the whole point is
that we're having an option to not put
the point did we manage to find Brett
here
I know so I was unable to get a hold of
him but I sent an email so maybe I'll
pop in okay so can we tell Brett that we
would we would like to use number point
to automatic by default for tick labels
okay done also for 12:1 right who knows
I mean it seems like oh okay whatever I
think he's got a scheme that's very much
like this for tick labels anyway yes he
did discuss a bit with him the other day
and he mentioned that in most cases it
does already do this right so I mean I'm
just saying let's formalize that and
just say this is how it's doing it
because I agree it does do this in those
cases right so perhaps it's more a
matter of finding examples of cases in
which it doesn't work right or just
formalizing this is what it's doing so
that you could switch it off if you
wanted to right you say number point
just have a number point option that
flows right into all the graphics into
the tick specifications okay looking
good okay now what happened
okay so Jonathan's predicate logic stuff
is that in here now yes indeed and and
that's and that's why we need to review
a fee a couple of notes okay great other
examples I hope they're examples of
examples there
yes okay do I need the very latest
version or not
no this hasn't changed we changed it
yesterday I was working with Jonathan on
this okay somebody is asking for
external evaluators I am going to show
you an external evaluator um I think
maybe I'm gonna show you how evaluator I
don't know if I am um come on
well that's up there we go that are a
Julia external evaluator anybody know
how to type anything into Julia do you
think I even have an installation aah
splat Oh somebody might ask Roger to
install this so I have this that wasn't
a very good demo could could um
Devin could you ask Roger to install
this please yeah along with the other
ones that are in this list Jeff
yummy screen shot okay thank you
okay well so sorry I can't demo it but
but the good news is it's there um okay
find equational proof so the first note
was changed and we kept the original so
that you compare what the heck oh did I
type the wrong thing
so excluded is the original and now we
so try to explain but F final equation
approach succeeds in deriving the
theorem thn from the axioms then it
returns a proof object expression
so it succeeds joining theorem cannot be
derived it returns a failure object so
to explain what reduction meant I think
this is good I like what you've done and
then the three possibilities because
that was another frequent question in
which cases what happens if you cannot
show either them right well undecidable
sorry guys
and undecidability turns into time
constraint um and then the next node
addresses their new way of expressing
things which one here know theorems who
cares that they're converted into
equation of form do you see it well if
you look at the proof itself you may see
things converted into sense that were
not equations pair equated to totallys
okay I see I see I see I see
so that's right then the very first line
in the definition box says find an
equation of proof so now we don't say
equation of theorem we just say equation
of proof because now the theorem can be
zero do we really want to say logic
theorem I mean it's not really logic
interested I think I think theorem of
the symbolic theorem THM using the
axioms something like that
um what do we mean by first order form
it means that you cannot have a means
you've got there exactly you have exists
do you have not exists well what this
means is that you cannot nest two
quantifiers 20 fires that one is fine
the other one we're given an equation of
form or in general first order form
paren with a single level general first
order form of a comma with it with a
single level of quantifier the
quantifiers can be nested they just they
have to be independent I see with this
okay or in general first order form with
a with a single level of dependent
quantifier or something without ok when
first order form first order logic form
can be given an equation of form or in
general first order logic form in first
on logic form dependent quantifiers
cannot be nested what about equational
form or as a formula and first-order
logic like rearranging the word somehow
a little bit yeah okay
as a formula and first yeah yeah I like
that other like that's better
construction on as formula can be given
an equation of form or as formulas in
first order logic
so what specifically can we do in first
order logic well we don't have to have
always equations now and we can use
things like implies well then let's list
what we can use we're given an equation
of form or as formulas in first order
logic and can contain okay so then an
equation or form can be any logical
conjunction of blah in first order logic
form they can be any logical conjunction
of blah right yes okay so what's the bla
so let's put that in oh why are we even
listing this I mean why don't we just
list them all together who cares whether
you can mix and match can't you yes okay
yes the idea is that those that are not
equations will D convert it into
equations and I understand I understand
can be given an equation or as formulas
in first order logic it's something like
everything is processed as equations
formulas in first order logic will
perform ulis in first order logic
are converted to equational form to an
equation or form that reasonable isn't
yep
okay so now statements can be any
logical conjunction of logical
conjunction is that right and
no wars does it have to be conjunctions
well the basic form is a list or a
conjunction of statements okay
very logical conjunction all okay so
what other things can you have in there
so we can have any boolean operators
implies okay so equation of logic okay
occasional logic okay so this universal
quantifiers over equation or logic
identities but so what is the general
form that we support now you know we
really should put these in lowercase
since we don't yet have mortal as a
built-in function okay maybe we will one
day have it as a built-in function but
we don't yet okay so let's take a look
at what this looks like because we got
to say somewhere that predicates are
written as arbitrary symbolic functions
right so I mean this thing here let's
take a look at whether we can prove that
Socrates is mortal um that's pretty nice
I mean the fact that takes 53 steps to
prove that Socrates as mortal as bit
dissapointing yes because it goes
through all this conversion steps okay
could we make that simpler well Jennifer
says that well myself has some sort of
non determinacy inside and sometimes
these numbers is smaller but I don't
think we have a way of controlling I see
okay anyway let's let's look at what
this looks like okay tries to find the
equation or proof of the symbolic
theorem okay I can I'm gonna remove
these
I don't think that should be hyphenated
it's not an adjective or form okay so
now let's try and write down what they
can be so explain again what what you
can actually put in there because you
don't need the equal T just needs a
predicate here the the statements can be
any logical conjunction or logical
anything of these things I think maybe
we should say should be conjunction of
terms and then explain what the terms
can look like right okay I think at the
top a logical conjunction of terms of
the form it's somewhat recursive start
with and of things and ORS and then well
let's let's get some requests let's get
some minutes let's get meet first
equation or logic identities okay so
then we've got f of blank blank blank
which is a predicate right correct
arbitrary symbolic predicate arbitrary
symbolic predicate
where do we say here that the operators
I mean you can have any operator you
want and I don't think it makes that
very clear well I mean that the form of
the LHS can be any symbolic expression
yes yes we have some groups using
Sprague's right so we this is completely
unclear from what's said here totally it
totally unclear something like this is
completely unclear so this isn't a
predicate what is this thing let's say
terms can okay so so so we have equation
an equation is working as the predicate
so equation can contain anything but the
object by itself cannot
no but okay hold on hold on
so the main point is that the this is a
predicate here this is now a predicate
but the let's call it P actually
arbitrary symbolic predicate
okay so then then what we got to say
here the expressions let's call it X
okay wait a minute I'm trying to explain
how we always say the LHS can be an
arbitrary symbolic expression with the
sides of the equation can be written
expressions
assertion of equality that's what that
really is okay then we say now okay so
what's the next thing we can say sure
can we say logical combination is it
true or is it just think in that case it
means conjunction no no it doesn't have
to be a conjunction
yes so the way this works following well
my star is that it takes a list of
statements and it assumes a conjunction
so that's why we start by that and then
all the operators and or so on and it's
also understood as a list of this basic
concept okay what is all or is
transformed into some equation of form
so all other logic combination
communities like like so on and so we
can say any logical combination it's
fine okay
okay so now what else is it down here
now we've got for all and there exists
right yes so inside for all we can have
any other videos right predicates
assertion expert okay not really explore
this this has to be something that
represents an assertion that the
predicate
pred is true for all values of VARs
perhaps it's the statement s TMT it's
like Fortran um okay
it's two for values of hours okay fine
okay and this case is abstinence or what
the two previous cases are statements so
I relegate is a particular case an
equation is nervous right now what about
there exists can we do that yes yes
okay okay now what do we say here so
then we say the X the X purse
the expressions expert I can be can have
arbitrary can contain arbitrary symbolic
the expert I can be arbitrary symbolic
expressions formal operators or abstract
operators are typically represented our
comparison both expressions in which
with heads representing what do we call
them formal abstract whatever
you
um I'm looking at a few livestream
comments all I'll get some more later
but I noticed Carl saying that it would
be good to have a tutorial or a
background in contact section for find
equational proof he's right yeah
somebody feel like writing one like a
tech note about it would be good yes can
be arbitrary symbolic expressions with
heads what how do we want to say this
with heads representing formal operators
or something yes or products I think
I've started two main cases okay
the statements st MT can consist of
arbitrary logical combinations of
predicates
are we considering like mortal from that
Socrates example to be an operator not
really I'm thinking of it as a predicate
maybe we want to say predicates
operators or relations let's remind
ourselves in the in mathematical logic
this notion of a language right they
have they have words for these there are
literals there are what are those things
can you remind me what those are because
we should just have a table that says
how you do each of those things right
right what are those things
there's relation symbols I don't know if
those are handled by the prover though
Jose yeah they all hand out that's the
whole point
relationship relation symbols predicates
do you have like just unary predicate
absolutely happy as a clam to have one
of those in symbols right function
relation operator predicated I mean that
a lot of things which have okay
representing formal operators functions
products etc my interesting formal
operators functions etc yeah and then
maybe explain better in the background
section which doesn't exist yet right
okay
okay mm-hm
looks good this isn't quite formatted
right that's the formatting needs to oh
my gosh the answer is no I cannot make
look yeah okay all right after looking
great okay one small question is
Jonathan was saying that now that data
set can support colors in individual
rows etc whether it's worth matching the
colors of the proof yes
Oh interesting idea also design has a
very big proof graph let's just make it
a little bit smaller
um yeah why not if we can perhaps just
in the header on the left yeah why not
but very light coloring okay cool
okay so that's about and now something
we have discussed you know is like the
connection between axiomatic theory and
finite good data
yep so I have selects them which is we
could make axiomatic theory return the
group axioms together with the relations
I think I'll be very cool very cool and
these can be passed directly to find the
question truth very very cool and my
opinion mm-hmm and this is very nice
I prefer to have it in Axum attic theory
rather than finite later because then it
can follow directly the notation of a
specification of product identity exit
right it is the last interred
okay so um the defining relations here
oh I see you can then give this
so that those aiibi represent the ten
and four SATA generators in the notation
of finer group later so finally that
goes for readability so it's very clear
but not very useful when an Exim attic
theory we have to express the products
in non associate what can I prove about
the tetrahedral group from this so for
example you can express all the elements
and prove all the relations like the
product of e times D times D is equal to
D times e times something so if I want
to just reduce the word in the
tetrahedral group for instance how would
I do that with this this depends on
what's my star and we don't think that
will Meister can do that
so what's Meister can prove a given
identity so you know there's no I
understand understand that I wonder if
there's a way that we could figure out I
mean I think you know this is clearly
simplification in an arbitrary axiomatic
system is another interesting problem I
think it would be I think we should
somebody should look at this I mean not
let me I'm gonna add this to my summer
school listen I think that's a good so
this is an area in which together with
what we have with well my star it would
be good to have that Ted Cox there
algorithm and then we could do some
interior computations
right what's involved and doing the toad
[ __ ] sort of thing
it's got the numeration is some sort of
reduction
okay um correlations I mean I wonder
well that's just an algorithm that we
could at least get for the function
repository to begin with the toad
coxeter thing needs to be fast enough
okay fair enough
well one of the things that may be good
classes except these days I I mean Tom
keeps on delivering compiler results he
just showed the one this morning there
was a thing that I'd wrote he managed to
make it eight times faster which I
thought was kind of lame but um okay
well this looks lovely okay
Kelly graph yeah that's another
discussion so I think so what I'm going
to suggest here is to follow the
sequence of colors used by graphics
which is quite nice so this is an
example followed ah that's just fine
this is just ugly and so decided first
two colors in that sequence perhaps
making it a bit thicker like that yeah I
think that's okay is us okay now these
other way me I think you suggested B's a
way of allowing EC specification of the
color of a given generator right so I'm
suggesting put that into Cana graph and
by the time it's in graph plot it's not
gonna have the time it's in graph it's
gonna have turned that into con some
kind of edge style specification it's no
longer going to have yes before I had to
specify the color of each individual
edge and you saw that wrong list so here
it will be a matter of specifying the
generator as a permutation with its
color
I understand but but by the time it's a
Gras
you can't post-process it if you want to
post process it you're back to doing
individual edge coloring that's fine I
mean you know same thing I plot to
graphics but I think ok can you slip
this in ASAP basically did did we ask
anybody whether there's a better choice
of a better color map than this one
because it might be that there's a
slightly nicer one to use with the color
schemes here you're basically looking
for an indexed color I don't know I mean
this looks okay to me I'm just I don't
know for sure I mean it would be good to
just ask somebody in design if they have
yeah I think I think Jeremy doesn't
Jeremy does not know what Kayla graphs
are and I don't blame hi this is okay
this is probably gonna be just fine
because I mean the point is in the
calligraphed other than for the free
group right we're gonna have more than
one color exactly I mean even well you
know even most important groups have
only two or three generators so it's not
something yes I understand
have a little discussion with them but
this looks fine if you can't come up
with anything else that looks just fine
okay
and then finally I wanted to point out
that the difference in options currently
between Kelly - grass it's just directed
edges because I was thought obviously
they the edges in a telegraph are
directed but I've seen sometimes people
representing them without the arrow so I
was wondering whether to reserve that
option in Kayla Grove why don't I don't
see why not
I mean I think it's not as useful
probably but it's not not obviously
ridiculous do you ever get like
different colors along the same between
the
same two vertices no no we're in it
between oh I see but a generator through
vertices here can you get there by
generator a as well as generator B is
the question no I mean can you get from
vertex one to vertex 2 via your first
generator but it's the second generator
that goes back no because it's a group I
mean if we did these four semigroups yes
but for a group right it's the inverse
isn't it
am i confused no no no no I'm confused
I'm totally confused I'm totally
confused that's a how we representing
inverse so the inverse okay basic Cayley
graphology okay this is a generator a
right this is a this is an order to
generator which is going back on the the
same that cycles one two and that's
probably cycles one two as well that's
an order to object right so so the
answer is that this is not just a
representation of the loop it's also a
representation of the choice of
generators for that group so what what
Bridget is saying is that imagine that
you specify in the generators G and the
inverse of G then you will have that
situation in this case it happens that
the G and inverse of G are the same and
that's why you have to add it in look
let's try a bigger I think think for
example of the inverse of the blue
generator yes if we added if the if this
generating set was these two generators
plus the inverse of the blue we would
have all cycles reversed with the arrows
in the opposite direction and the
article I see I see I see so there's
just a shadow Kayla crop that's the
whole thing turn backwards right which
isn't very interesting we don't show it
exactly well once you had a generator
you never had it in the generating such
dangerous can you tell me something
which has more than two generators
a billion group to teach oh come on we
can do better than two to two okay so
this would presumably this is a graph
right so I can presumably say graph 3d
of this okay so we should check that the
new specify I mean these these colors
don't look as bad in 3d you get some
training going on so it helps that did
these colors if Jose is proposing to use
the default colors from III I don't know
I'd prefer something a little bit Joey
uh perhaps can you do color data of
ninety seven color list everybody likes
the 97 one
it's our default it's what our defaults
are based on two arguments okay I know
I'm just saying I'm asking is there
something a little bit jollier than that
blue right
do I look through the indexed colors
here and it's the same list is that they
look better in in plot itself so if you
compare to plot y is that plot thicker I
see well maybe this should go pick up
but then what happens when you get a
very dense Kayla graph I think I'd be
happy do we need to get Jeremy here to
see if we can get Jeremy just for a
moment I haven't a clue what to do here
can we experiment with I haven't a clue
I mean is okay no now look at 98
which i think is jollier or at least
it's it is turning it is Julia yeah I
think that's better can we can we try 98
here yes it's a matter of changing this
c1 and c2 the Karass thing okay so it's
basically c1 is so if I just say c1 is
color color data 98 of 1 is that right
it should be raped and then you need to
evaluate s4 which is the grass
okay they need to go thick up how do we
do that directive by these C sub eyes
need to be directives what would you
recommend thick is the easiest one
probably
it seems a bit thick but let's try this
also for let's try setting this let's
just try s 4 equals K leg off of like
symmetric group of six elements or
something just see something a little
bit denser Stephen I just joined to and
I sent you my notebook of what I was
working on which is pretty close to this
splash what happened here well this is
these are the edges for us for as we
said before we have to work on the edges
invisible oh I see I see I see
horrifying okay okay so that's not gonna
work okay Jeremy just a minute did you
just send me an e-mail the yeah yeah and
there's some code to plug-in colors a
little easier
yeah I just didn't like the yellow in 97
it was a little too light so I tweaked
the colors a little bit and a version of
97 with a little better colors yeah
that's completely doable
that's it partly there's some opacity a
little bit of a faster V there and it
lightens every color that you give it so
there's you have to give it a little
brighter and darker colors are you happy
with a note color here I lightened it I
didn't like B of the default node
because it just felt like it was jumping
out too much you see really the node
point so I didn't feel like you needed a
big blob there let's talk group theory
for a second do you want to see the node
point so do you not want to see them I
don't think you want to see them
particularly do they have tooltips on
them are they there's a version where
you can do that like if you scroll down
there you know fine that's you know but
the the node there isn't some both the
nodes and the edges are group elements
so that's why I both have tips right I
see I see I see I see so this is a
location setting that that thing but in
general the important things are the
edges yeah the default a little bit of
blue and it's darker and it just they
just stood out and you know I'm kind of
detracted from everything else so so do
we think this is a this is better yeah
it's kind of neutral gray and it doesn't
you know we don't need another color
when we've got all this color going on
okay so this is the more can i this
would have default yes do I evaluate
just random one of these yeah any of
those should work
there's only so much you can do with a
case like this that has so much going on
so it's thinner line start starts to
help when it gets really dense
I think it looks decent anybody else
comments on this I mean things a lot
better than was before I think so I
think you know especially when it starts
to get busy switching a wreck away from
the directed edges would probably help a
lot okay how do we feel about that seems
okay the green is losing it a bit boy
it's cool that you can just make a
k-leaguer
look at that that's an abelian group I
can tell those colors aren't as good for
3d we might have to do something they
get dark at certain angles right really
dark but the tubes well so the green
tubes look thinner than the other tubes
I don't know why I think there's a
difference in value with the green
somehow no I think they are thinner
somehow for some reason the greens
really light looking compared to the
orange which I don't get all right so
that's an issue but but I think we're
close here I mean the the the green
could go a little bit more verdant lis
green so to speak perhaps
and then it might help in this case mmm
really cool you can do this okay all
right so do we think we have a solution
here what close you've got Jose you're
gonna have something to install a next
day or two hopefully yes okay um okay
I'm Brett you had been involved that the
number point discussion we wanted you to
be part of that this is the new Nava
point our automatic that doesn't put
points off to things right I mean in
general the ticks don't
ah
Ethan our live stream is suggesting news
in the news shading primitive I don't
know which shading primitive would use
one of the tune shade I we don't have we
just have lines here we don't have
enough we don't have a enough of
polygons to shade yeah I mean those
tubes are so narrow that anything you do
is gonna get lost okay let me just um
I'm just gonna look at some live stream
things we got a wrap in a moment here
Carl is asking for syntax highlighting
for external languages we are well aware
of that issue that is sort of in flight
that it's complicated and ast
functionality were also aware of that
we've had some early projects which
actually we should see if we can get
that project and the function repository
we we have a project that makes s T's
for any could somebody find out if Chris
Gulas project for making a STS for
external languages could go in the
function repository that's a question
for Devon to ask God
you
okay question is external language
interface for our using our link anybody
know the answer to that I think the
answer is yes but I don't know for sure
um
carl is asking for domain-specific
languages i don't know exactly what one
means by that because you can respec I
anything if you want to change the
syntax that's a whole different kind of
worms you know everything that I did in
SMP I'll eventually redo in Wolfram
language after a 35 year recovery period
because it didn't work in SMP of which
syntax rewriting was one classic example
of absolutely horrifying thing I've been
nice to get back the proofs graph and
and KS book style which which it's an
interesting suggestion I have to
remember which style were talking about
there hold on is going up weird um so
the main proof and the n KS book is the
one
oh you mean things like this
Oh can of worms do you understand what
this is Jose why is it the one I press
magnify here it doesn't magnify this
part of thee it's magnifying the fonts
and even margins but there's constraint
on how big that images is trying to be a
certain percentage of the page width of
your browser width right and you can
only get so big so as it actually gets
smaller because as the elements enlarge
ya age is still constrained and so we
have this other solution that we're
implementing okay somebody sent in this
idea for JavaScript to make these things
pop out which seemed like a really good
idea anyway umm okay but so what this is
is this is indicating what the rewrite
that's being done here is you see what
I'm saying
yes I'm wondering whether how would you
spread the critical elements which have
like two legs what are these these are
pure substitutions right you say are
only a part of the story exactly
so you're saying substitutions are which
ones so we have the Lamaze in which
there is a clear sister substitution
okay there's a substitution lemma right
okay which in this case is using a
number from the axiom list to say which
substitution it is and that's just
applying the substitution right okay
that is a critical pair lemma why is the
saying Yelper backtick cons twelve bars
we need a way to specify all this
unification as accepted and we have
formed a good way to express them formal
variables or at least variables numbered
variables but the yell proved urbact ik
is surely not the right answer by the
way for that for that documentation can
we please look up I remember that in the
in the in textbooks of mathematical
logic things when you talk about a
language for a logical system they're
things like constants and so on that
they're a bunch of terms that they used
but we should fix that I mean that's
goofy okay but you're saying the
critical pair lemma depends on some
other results here yes it's a way of
combining two previous statements unify
them you it's you know yeah well this
isn't that this is just pure
substitution I mean I think I had
another one here this horrifying thing
here so it may still be the case that we
can get a substitution from the critical
problem oh but they they how well where
does it come from I well you know what
this is actually not a bad thing either
this is pretty nice that has that's a
lemma the great thing is a lemma and
then this is using lemma such-and-such
Bluff there's the result using lemon
such-and-such Bluff as the result so
what that corresponds to in this diagram
is
not sure there's that there's a way of
mapping this entities we should look at
that it's a good suggestion is silly we
hadn't looked at that before because
these things
I mean considerable effort was put into
making these things look decent um okay
ah page 810 thank you what page I'm on
yes okay good we're talking about the
same thing come on specify the proof by
hand to validate it
if automated derivation fails we don't
have a good way I mean the
representation of that proof there is a
symbolic representation of that proof
right what is that symbolic
representation it's internal form of
proof object which is very close to the
proof what is the thing called proof
function function yes but this is also a
yeah it's a subset of horrifying things
yes this is what I was saying before we
need ways to express on the meaning here
they call this map that its unification
has in the system functions that do that
represents correctly the unification we
should talk about this this is a
separate topic this is an interesting
topic but this is basically representing
this is representing patterns on both
sides of an expression in some sense yes
it's it's taking two expressions to two
substitution rules and combining them to
form another one yeah okay suggestion
about real-world examples pages that's
interesting idea to do it that way to
just
right to take I'd said yeah Devon if you
just put that in the documentation that
suggestion and just add it to our
documentation dozen yeah got it it's a
good idea
find equational conjectures analog for
geo stuff what does that mean
conjecture that says the area of you
don't understand what that could
possibly mean um just meant an analog of
fine geometric conjectures but for
equational proof no no no for geo stuff
was the suggest first this vertical
trigonometry or something yeah
eventually how are we doing on that all
the spherical distance and so on things
did that did that project get get
underway the Geo stuff for a unit sphere
type thing
yes no I haven't worked on that at some
point we thought perhaps having it
having those functions in their function
repository
oh boy I'm being told it's in in eight
minutes time which is not right now
we'll hit 500 hours of live streaming
these these kinds of meetings so I think
it's time to wrap up and we can start
our next meeting by by celebrating our
500 hour milestone so we'll have to get
to these another time
great ok thanks for very much thanks to
folks on the livestream see you all soon